all right Eric yes Erica where'd you
grow up where are you from
I'm from New Orleans Louisiana
um I've been here practically my whole
life
you tell me about your family
um I was born uh in a wealthy family I
come from a wealthy family my mother
she is born and raised in New Orleans
and um her father was a Oil Man and um
he struck oil in Texas I think in the uh
late 50s early 60s
and um she had a very good childhood
um went to private schools her whole
life grew up across the street from uh
Archie Payton and Eli Manning In the
Garden District
um basically uh she's a professional
tennis player you know I had a pretty
good childhood so to speak
but you got in trouble yes I had gotten
in trouble
um a lot throughout my life uh the first
time when I was 17 I was arrested for
obstruction of justice
um possession of ecstasy
and uh drunk and disorderly con conduct
in the French Quarter
um I had gotten in big trouble in 2018
um one of my buddies had called me when
I was on my way to work and um I was
doing a painting job
by the Magnolia projects and um he had
called me while I was on my way to work
and he said hey I need a ride so I was
like man I'm on my way to work I said I
really don't have time well at that time
I was strung out on heroin probably had
a grandma day heroin habit 100 a day and
um he said I said I'm on my way to work
and he was like man I have a eight ball
of heroin come pick me up you know I'll
get you loaded well I said okay I'll
call my boss and tell him I'll be a few
minutes late
so he told me to pick him up at Walmart
in Kenner when I when Kenner is on the
outskirts of New Orleans probably about
15-20 minutes away
so when I went and picked him up at
Walmart he had gotten into my car with a
book bag and a pistol
so at that time my heart started
pounding a mile a minute and asked him
what's going on he said
man if the police get behind us just
know I'm throwing down with them
and uh basically I'm not going down
they're gonna have to kill me so I'm
like dude what is going on you know and
he said uh you haven't watched the news
I'm like dude what is what's going on
man
and uh he said I robbed the bank
yesterday and I'm thinking oh [__] what
have I gotten myself into
well anyways uh I said look man I gotta
go to work where do you need to get
dropped off at so uh he said drop me off
at Church's Chicken on Claiborne
so I brought him there and um he had
gotten me high and uh gave me a hundred
dollar bill and said look
um
what time do you get off work and I had
told him uh I'd say four or five o'clock
he said when you get off give me a call
and um if you can give me a ride
somewhere
you know I'll compensate you so I said
okay
well I went to work didn't think much of
it as I'm getting off of work I really
you know I had the hundred dollars he
had given me that morning
but um you know I could I was thinking I
could sure use the money at that time
especially with my habit
so I called him I said where do you need
to go he said uh can you bring me to
Baton Rouge I'm uh I'm gonna catch a bus
so I said okay I said uh you know I
asked him what exactly did you do man
and he said I went into the Gulf Coast
Bank on Veterans Boulevard and uh I
walked in I raised the pistol to two
tellers and said both of y'all empty the
drawers or we're gonna have all of us
are gonna have a really bad day
so he arm robbed the bank uh
he had just gotten out of federal prison
from doing 27 years in federal prison
and gotten relapsed gotten back on drugs
and that's pretty much what uh led him
to do something that crazy but um
I gave him a ride to Baton Rouge and um
he he didn't have an ID he said man can
you rent a hotel room for me I said sure
I'll do it you know I did it for him we
went to his room we got high and uh he
gave me 300 and that was the last time
I've ever seen him I went about my
business
and uh the next day is where everything
pretty much
you know everything started collapsing
in my life what happened then
um I I went to work like nothing
happened it was pretty good day I got
off of work
um went inside and my girlfriend who's
my wife now at the time she was my
girlfriend I had went inside we were
talking you know and uh I was like babe
I'm going to clean my paint brushes
would you like to come you know talk to
me while I do it and she said sure I'll
come talk to you
so I had my back facing the street and I
was Clint my uh water service is right
by my front door in my old apartment and
I had my back face in the street and um
I'm sitting there cleaning my paint
brushes and she's looking at me but
she's facing in the direction of the
street so she can see cars coming and
going and whatnot so um
she's standing there and all of a sudden
I see a look on her face her eyes got
huge and she's like what is going on
right now and I looked over my shoulder
and here comes Suburbans all kind of
unmarked cars jumping out with in suits
with badges around her neck
and uh instantly I you know effed and
went to go run inside because I had
drugs in my pocket I had cocaine
marijuana and a few bags of heroin in my
pocket and as soon as I went to go
inside she said stop don't run by this
time they got their guns out saying stop
stop
you know so I just stood there and uh
the first guy ran with a gun in my face
he says why are you trying to run why
are you trying to run I said I didn't
know who y'all were you know so by this
time about eight officers come over here
and they're like where is he where is
Andy where's Andy I said man I don't
know where Andy is you know
so the first cop says search them so
they searched me he said man why were
you trying to go inside I said to be
honest with you I have weed on me he
said um okay where is it I said it's in
my right pocket
so he cuffed me he starts patting my
pockets he pulls a bag of weed out I was
like okay I'm good they didn't find the
crack or the heroin so he passed me down
I think I'm good they set me on the
ground
and they uh they asked my girlfriend if
they could go in the house and look
around so they're looking around for
this bank robber and um
they don't find them they clear the
house well another cop walks up and says
man search them one more time and then
that's when they did a thorough search
and I looked down in the heroin cracked
they were balled up in a toilet paper I
see it fall on the ground and I tried to
step on it and that's when he's like
nice try buddy lift your foot up
and then The Jig was up they had found
it and
basically um yeah
you went to uh
prison I went to Jefferson Parish
Correctional Center and um
I had went there and uh they booked me
on uh accessory to armed robbery and a
possession of heroin and they had booked
me on uh possession of schedule two
crack cocaine and um my bond was forty
thousand dollars
and uh after a few weeks I had posted
bail my girlfriend had posted bail for
me
how much time do you do
um on that I was sentenced to drug court
but prior to this uh about a year prior
to this
I had just gotten out of prison for
doing four years
four years in one week I did in uh
prisons all around Louisiana
are you the only one in your family uh
yes I'm the black sheep of my family
what do you think that is
honestly if I
probably probably my uh my upbringing
guidance I didn't really have that in my
life structure I didn't you have
siblings uh yes I have one sister and I
have a half brother
do they have similar childhoods oh yes
my sister and I grew up in the same
household and uh my half brother
I don't really know too much about his
childhood other than we have the same
dad and he wasn't around for either of
our lives so
but uh my sister and I grew up in the
same household and uh
yeah her and I are polar opposite you
know
but you're doing better now
yes I'm doing better I'm on maintenance
I've got a steady job I've been doing
Plumbing work pretty much
um since I got on that program after
being arrested in connection with the
bank robbery and uh yeah it's been a
struggle though you know
um
I have a son
um he was diagnosed about nine months
ago with autism and uh when I found that
out we wanted to get him tested because
he was showing signs about two years old
I started to notice things and um
you know just was like concerned so you
know I started talking to somebody and
they told me you know that sounds a
little bit like autism and I was like
autism you know I really didn't know too
much about it and I started you know
doing research and stuff and I was like
you know I really pray that it's not
autism but all signs were pointing
towards it and uh we had got them tested
and yep I found out he had autism and it
kind of broke me I'm not gonna lie I was
in a dark place you know for a few
months because of it and it really
weighed down on me
and um everything's getting better now
I'm starting to accept it and just
trying to move forward and be the best
version of myself that I can be for him
is there any temptation to go back to
your previous life
um as far as criminal like um doing
illegal stuff for money like uh the
stuff that had landed me in prison for
four years and uh the stuff that I did
that I almost got a life sentence behind
or football numbers behind uh absolutely
not but
you know probably if I didn't
have uh job skills now like uh Tradesmen
who knows where I would be you know but
uh
once I started learning the skill I
started you know being able to make
support my habit by working
you know I uh think think twice about
doing something that's going to put me
back in prison probably because of my
son I think about him and my wife first
and uh
I know if I go back to prison I'm gonna
lose everybody in my life
and you know it wouldn't be the first
time that I've lost everything and
now I've just came to a point where I'm
like you know I'm tired of lying to my
wife I'm tired of hurting the people I
care about you know she's found me
overdosed before you know and it was
really scary situation for somebody who
doesn't
do drugs or was never involved with a
person who's from the streets or you
know been to prison or you know so all
of that I basically exposed her to all
of that you know
and I feel guilty a lot about it
I feel guilty a lot about it and um
you know sometimes I wish that I could
do things a little bit differently
but I'm
basically I know all I can do is try to
live better and try to do better moving
forward
but it's a struggle you know what would
you say you're more hopeful now or more
fearful
um both kind of honestly you know I uh
I'm like with the trade I'm learning uh
Plumbing you know I'd had no job skills
my whole life basically was working
[__] jobs or pretty much wherever
whoever would give me a job and a lot of
the times with my record it was hard to
get a job anywhere you know so I'd
basically take whatever I could
and a guy gave me a chance with plumbing
and uh I took it and ran with it and
once I started learning I saw the type
of money I could be making and you know
I felt good to actually know how to do
something you know and um because my
whole life and never really had you know
any type of hobbies skills
um
yeah pretty much never had an
opportunity like that you know to learn
and better myself so when I had gotten
that opportunity I took it and ran with
it
what fears do you have
honestly the fears that I have is um
just falling back into
my old ways as far as
like just being head first and active
addiction you know disappearing
um
Staying High losing my job
um losing my son and my wife that would
I would be devastated you know
but um
I really don't want to go back
back to my old life are there addicts in
your family yes
my mother she um she died into that
January 13 2007
um my sister found her dad she had
overdosed on
um well she was dead with her eyes open
in bed and um you know they called an
ambulance and I was at my friend's house
drinking
and uh taking Xanax and stuff and I had
went over there because I had seen a
police car in an ambulance so I'm like
what's going on I'll walk in a house and
I've seen uh the man who raised me David
his British man
and uh he was crying and I've never seen
that man shed a tear a day in my life
and he was crying and I look up and I
seen a police officer walking down the
stairs and I said what's going on
and my sister looked at me and said
she's gone
and I said what do you mean and my dad
said well my stepdad he said she's dead
and I tried to go upstairs and you know
see and the cop was basically being a
dick to me like pushing me back saying
you can't go up there you can't go up
there and I started acting irrational
and stuff and uh just was hysterical you
know
and um he's like you can't go up there
and I was just like you know acting
belligerent he's like you keep it up I'm
going to detain you and uh I went and
sat outside and went back to my friend's
house and basically uh
drunk myself to Oblivion
you know and just
um
that night I lost probably one of the
only people I ever felt that loved me
before my wife and my son you know
you know that was devastating because I
felt alone after that I felt like I
didn't have anybody really and truly I
didn't have anybody after that happened
you know and it was very um
it's been a very heartbreaking Journey
since that day sounds like your wife has
been very supportive though yeah she's a
great woman and uh man I'm I'm just so
blessed to have somebody like that in my
life
I honestly a lot of the times I feel
like I don't deserve it you know or I
feel like I'm not worthy it's a huge
part of it you know I feel like that all
the time man you know I feel like a
junkie you know I feel like
you know like I'm a criminal like you
know I just um
I don't know
I just feel like uh she could do better
than me you know
but
it's it's hard I live with a lot of
guilt and shame and uh
I just wish that um I could do things
would have done things different but a
part of me I think every day like I'm
kind of glad that you know I made these
mistakes because this is what led me to
the family that I have now and I'm
thankful for them you know every day
that's probably the most important thing
in my life but I think working on how
you see yourself like if you see
yourself as a drug addict Criminal
you know
it's you know just hanging on by a
thread
you need to see yourself as somebody
who's worthy of the love of your wife
absolutely you know and she um
like he don't see me as any of that you
know
and um she's very supportive you know
she always just tries to you know give
me to be responsible and just do the
right thing all the time she tells me
like I'll bring something up you know
like maybe a dumb idea so you know
maybe get money an easy way and she's
like no you're not gonna do that you're
gonna you know do it the right way you
don't want to have to worry about
looking in your rearview mirror or your
door coming down you know like I've had
that happen to me several times because
of you know dealing drugs or just
running from the police you know evading
the rest and capture
and it's just
she's definitely been a great influence
in my life you know
I'm very thankful to have her
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
the most important lesson that I've
learned in life is to
just work hard and be an honest person
and you know just be good to people even
if being good to people you know gets
gets a knife in your back or you know
you get betrayed don't stop being good
just learn how to learn the type of
people
to be good too you know
so um that's basically it
as far as you know the biggest lesson
I've learned in life
excellent all right Eric thank you so
much for sharing your story not a
problem Mark thank you for asking you
and your family lots of luck from here
thank you thanks